now let's talk about presidential
politics because as Bloomberg reported
yesterday
Joe Biden officially launches bid for
re-election in 2024. when I ran for
president four years ago I said we're in
a battle for the soul of America and we
still are
the question we're facing is whether in
the years ahead we have more freedom or
less Freedom more rights are fewer I
know what I want there is
this is not a time to be complacent
that's why I'm running for reelection
because I know America Joe Biden will be
82 years old in 2024. Joe Biden has some
form of Dementia or some other cognitive
problem
Dr Jill Biden his wife does not care
despite the fact that she's a very
important and very influential doctor
and Joe Biden is basically the perfect
vessel for all these ridiculous woke
ideas that's all he is he is just a sort
of brainless
swamp creature zombie who puts out
whatever reads whatever they want him to
read
often poorly mumbles and stumbles he has
no real support he's sort of just
perfect for what they are ushering in
but what's interesting about this is
everyone kind of knows it there are very
few hardcore Joe Biden supporters the
voter Market if you want to talk about
the market and market share related to
beer related to what people watch well
how about related to voting too the
market does not want him to run so let's
not give it to him here's Chuck Todd on
NBC even admitting that most people do
not want Joe Biden's run more than half
of the people who voted for him in 2020.
53 of 2020 Biden voters say he shouldn't
run 64 percent of Democrats who voted
for Sanders were worn in the 2020
primaries think he shouldn't run and 76
percent of Voters under 35 think he
shouldn't run and what's the top concern
for that we asked voters we didn't
prompt them we said why don't you think
he should run well these were the
responses it almost is all about his age
and his ability to do the job again
these are among Democratic primary
voters I want to just hit something
again about the age because this is just
going to keep coming up and keep coming
up I do generally believe that at 82
years old you should not be president of
the United States like it's just time to
go be a grandfather not that those
grandchildren want to be near him with
the sniffing of the hair and all that
stuff but like it's just too old but I
would also say in the world that we live
in now where the last 20 years have have
been an absolute revolution of
technology and information and
communication the idea that Joe Biden is
going to lead us to the other side of
that is so stagnated and so crazy and so
it's such a broken nonsensical idea that
again I think it's perfect for the
Democrats because they don't want the
new world to be ushered in they want a
world to be ushered in that will be of
more centralized control and of more
power over your decisions and much more
but it is not specifically about his age
and I just do want to say that one more
time my problem with Joe Biden it really
isn't despite I think you can make a
good argument about that right he grew
up in a completely different world we
need leaders who are somewhere in their
40s and 50s even into their 60s right
now
[Music]
thank you